the Joe Rogan experience the the main
question here in my mind is whether
there is evidence that supports being on
a 100% plant-based diet with no animal
products versus a diet that includes a
lot of plant foods and some animal foods
I thought you were backing the film
which was talking about plant-based
diets so plant-based diets means getting
the vast majority of calories from
plants well anything or excluding animal
foods but the film essentially was all
about only eating plants no kill you
dairy products will kill you that claim
was never made see but there was a
connection there was not there was a
third connection no there was not - what
was the connection the connection
cigarettes was the the the way the
PlayBook is being used by the Sivas
people are conflating like what the hell
PlayBook is the same the same way using
athletes and they're using advertising
we never made the claim which is lean
that then would be clear so the PlayBook
that was used by the the smoking
industry so they pay for studies right
right and and we know even with food
right this has been done with cigarettes
it's been done with drugs it's been done
with food research shows that
industry-funded studies of four to four
to eight times more likely to have a
conclusion in their favor for their
product so this is what the smoking
industry did then they got doctors to
say that smoking wasn't bad and then
they got athletes the show like hey
smoking is good that was the parallel
that we drew we never do that the
parallel that was drawn in what the hell
so I want to make that really clear
there was no and I've seen this in in
articles saying you know they they
connected me we didn't do that and if
you watch the film we never said I did
you why did you have that in there
though if you're not saying because
they're using the same playbook if
you're not saying that meat causes
cancer you're saying the same place if
ik claims that chicken eating chicken
and fish causes cancer eating dairy
causes cancer doctors vegan doctors know
they're not weak and that's the other
person vision so can I just go back can
we just finish the evaluating evidence
Naida at each point every critique so
basically the
and you're saying they're changing
overtime they are changing because as we
get better at signs that becoming more
the recommendations becoming more
plant-based despite industry influence
from studies and marketing and people
being paid off industry influence goes
both ways the sugar industry in the 60s
I agree expose pointing the finger at
fad I's the culprit so that's a straw
man argument it's not he's not saying
you are saying that the sugar industry
is terrible and I would agree that but
can I just agree just finish the F value
evident but the thing about this section
of the film was you were making some
sort of a correlation between cigarettes
and the way that it was marketed the way
they're marking away then the way meat
is marketed correct so it's the same
company's exponent but why would you do
you would never do that about like
carrots or kale or predominantly healthy
but I didn't because I didn't do it but
if you're saying that you you you you're
connecting the two things you're
connecting something that clearly causes
cancer cigarettes now and these studies
that were made to show people that it
didn't they were paid off the studies
were fake there was there were
essentially cherry-picked fake studies
that were financed by the tobacco
industry direct in order to get people
to buy more cigarettes you're making
this same sort of claim about me correct
which means you think that meat is bad I
do okay yes but that's where we're
that's where I we're not we can disagree
I'm almost finished with the evaluating
evidence so so basically what we did
when we expert interview the experts is
we chose leading experts in their
individual fields we collectively with
thousands of articles in the
peer-reviewed literature right so and
this is one of the bummers about the
making of documentaries like you put the
lower third on people don't get to read
it so we had the chair of nutrition at
Harvard the president of American
College of Cardiology the lead delegate
of urology of the American Medical
Association the chair of anthropology at
Harvard the director of energy
environment and resources at Chatham
House really respected so it took about
vegan doctors I saw some of them some
one were involved in hunting some were
involved in animal testing I saw one of
them eating a chicken sandwich at lunch
said let's not say that like this was a
vegan bias coming into it because that's
just not true this
we're stretching out here and this is we
were talking just about this one section
were you connecting cigarettes and meat
so you're saying that a session Sordo
deserves the same playbook but there's
no evidence that meat is bad for you no
but this is something that's actually
recently been established by mainstream
medicine you understand that right that
they've released new studies releasing
these new studies saying that there's no
longer this concern that red meat causes
cancer
this is also an appeal to an authority
because I can find many illustrious
doctors and experts who are highly
qualified that will disagree with my
point of view that that a diet must be a
hundred percent plant-based and I didn't
say you did but this was the connection
that you made with cigarettes in the
film no yes I think both promoting
something bad because there's a profit
so you think that meat is bad for there
promoting it knowing that it's bad yes
for profit okay so so all Chris has to
do to debunk the film right is convinced
the people watching and listening that
he knows more about the consensus and
the experts in their field like I would
understand this is not that interested
in consensus of experts I'm looking at
that research that is published the
peer-reviewed research that is published
yeah the meta analyses and even reviews
of meta analyses that have been done a
perfect example is the whole dairy in
cancer section totally that we talked
about where you had argued or Walter
Willett argue that there's you know
dairy products cause cancer and I
pointed to a meta analyses that looked
at over a hundred and fifty different
reviews that 84% of those found no
associations so how is that not part of
this discussion where we're talking
about hundreds of scientists across
different continents different countries
they're using peer reviewed so science
will show this but in the movie just one
expert is pointing to you know one group
of studies without mentioning that
that's just one right so this is the
2018 meta not so have you got a slide
for that
if not I've got your slide 107 slide
hundred and seven no this is a 2019 1953
studies right
yeah and I can get I'm really a lot
further into it not the only one I'd
love to because at nine o'clock last
night until nine o'clock last night I
thought Chris just made a bunch of
mistakes interpreting the data and I'm
going to show you how he has misleading
people on this study okay so if you can
bring up slide 107 Timmy is that can we
see this like yeah okay this is it okay
so you see what he's putting quotes okay
84% of meta-analyses on dairy
consumption showed either no association
or an inverse association between dairy
and cancer and then you go on to point
out what an inverse means is that people
ate more dairy get lower rates of cancer
that's what he's implying when you put
something in quotes what does that mean
to you it means us what he said yeah but
it's that that quotation is quoting the
study right fair enough
is that what they said in the study no
that's not what they said in the study
that's right my summary of the evidence
of the study right thank you but when
you put something quite that's mislead
but his quote okay fine but he's not
putting things in one else totally I
mean that's how when you when you when
you anything you do in literature when
you put some in quotation marks you're
quoting the study but let's just let's
just bypass that I'll agree okay so can
you bring up side 109 see what they
actually said okay this is the actual
quote 10 out of 153 reported meta
analyses comparing highest versus lower
dairy consumption 109 71% showed no
evidence of a systole significant
association between dairy consumption
and instance of cancers 20 showed a
decreased risk of cancers with dairy
consumption and 24 showed an increased
risk of cancers with daring sumption now
this is actually until last night like 9
o'clock I realized what he was doing
okay if you want to go to I mean just to
sum it up if you go to slide 110 wait
can we stand here interpretation what do
you
do you agree that that was the quote
from the study okay good but I'm asking
you what your interpretation it does
that in your mind show a strong
connection between dairy and cancer okay
Joe you're gonna really realize here
what Chris is doing okay this is really
and I'm glad that you bought it please
answer okay so can I just say the reason
you brought this up is because Walter
well it's that there was a strong
connection tree in prostate cancer and
dairy correct yeah so you brought about
something about all cancers okay yeah so
and in this study about half of the
study showed a connection between
prostate cancer and dairy and half
didn't right so not a compelling
argument that dairy is associated with
cancer okay so can we got you got a
coin-flip basically slide 110 well let's
let's stay with this explain this first
not we'll move to the okay so no widened
excellent is explaining okay it's just
breaking that down okay so there was
three significant associations between
dairy consumption instead of cancers
71 percent showed no evidence thirteen
showed a decreased risk in a sixteenth
century an increased risk so you see
what Chris did to represent this he
added 71 and thirteen to make 84 right
well this is how you got it right so you
added seventy three percent seventy one
percent and 13 percent to Gaetti four
right so his statement from this study
was 84 percent showed no evidence or
decreased risk that's what he made you
believe
well 71 percent shows no evidence the 13
percent shows decrease right circle you
add the two of them together it's 84
percent shows no evidence agree we're at
increased risk exactly but he could have
said his 71 percent plus six teams and
that's 87 percent he could have said 87
percent showed no evidence or an
increase for us it's eighty four
thousand one plus 16
oh so I I could make the claim no
evidence or a decrease we're getting
really interested
proof you were claiming in the film was
claiming dairy causes cancer my claim
was there's no the burp the bulk of the
evidence suggests there is no
association or inverse association
that's true shows no I agree
13% shows decreased risk okay so the
hold on a second yeah the decreased risk
and the increased risk are almost the
same which is how 3% shows interest and
this one's not the point of this study
is that this is his study that he
brought up showing this is very strong
evidence okay his statement was very
misleading
he added up those two and then he
finished it up by saying so basically
there's an inverse correlation but he
did not show he could have said 87%
showed no risk or an increased risk
insurance Ted he chose to summarize it
saying 84% but there's no risk discrete
increased risk it's not during Joe
because we're talking about something
causing cancer know exactly and so they
couldn't there wasn't showing of things
to find the total cancer was increased
right but we just we know that as
research shows this included did it not
industry funded research um two thirds
of researches in right now we know that
research shows like are you are you
proposing that we throw out every study
because the one of the main studies in
your film was sponsored by the Hass
avocado board the one that claims that
animal products contribute to
inflammation I'm not sure I'm not sure
that's right now I'm saying that
industry-funded studies and by the way
industry-funded studies they typically
only put them out when it shows in their
favor there's no obligation for industry
when they do a study to release it yeah
I'm primarily a retired okay what do you
think that the industry and the meat and
dairy is far more money than the
plant-based industry right you'd agree
with that
actually we can look at some statistics
on that Joe I don't know okay would you
did would you disagree that industry
funded research has a four to eight
times increased risk compared to non
industry funded research in fine
inclusions in their favor I think is I
think industry research is definitely a
problem but I see it as a problem across
the board and I have some statistics and
so
do you know do you not admit that you
here led the audience to believe that
there was a potentially decreased risk
overall you made it sound very high
because you didn't split between them no
different that was not my intention it
was just it was a data's not to spend
ten minutes as we're doing now talking
about one study no it's not accurate if
there said showed no evidence or showed
an increased risk 84% daddy so 87 said
that seems like it's miss Lee I think
that would be misleading also he could
say we're talking about something
causing cancer James exactly so he
should be making increased risk is what
we're looking for
well writing for evidence of it causing
cancer 71% the bulk of the evidence
shows no evidence that's exactly what
I've my point doesn't show that you
honestly don't think that that statement
instead of just putting the subform
Center no evidence 13% show that would
be the fairest the most you know honest
explanation like summary of that
statement I would say that if you wanted
to say it the most accurately yes that's
the best way to say one percent showed
no evidence 13 percent showed decreased
risk but I don't have a problem with
saying 84 percent showed no evidence or
a decreased risk truth cuz were to try
out something causing cancer that's the
that's the relevant point the relevant
point is does the studies show that
dairy causes cancer the the primary
evidence that most of the evidence says
it shows no evidence or it shows a
decreased risk that's the bottom of the
bulk of the 84 percent versus 87 percent
it does no no no 87 percent shows
increased risk is only 16% no evidence
to increased risk to get 87 percent okay
let's throw out the no evidence let's
throw out nobody threw out the burden of
proof is to show evidence that indicates
that dairy causes cancer if you do a
study and it shows that it doesn't then
that's not in support of the claim I'm
agreeing that the meta-analysis did not
could not find an association but I'm
also pointing out that industry funded
studies
included in it and they are more likely
to find no connection so there's a
hundred fifty three studies you're
claiming we should just that all of them
are industry funded and we should throw
out this huge review of one hundred and
fifty three meta analyses because of
industry funding what is the basis for
that claim no I'm not I'm saying that it
sways the results can you you can't see
that I don't I don't like but you know I
don't accept it I have a hundred you
just III studies you accept they were
that they were in this meta analyses
that they're gonna sway the results to
the point where these findings aren't
valid and we could do the same thing
with this all of the studies that you
have linked to in the film well we can
we can also look at other studies on
dairy and cardio metabolic outcomes that
we have got lots of large reviews that
we can look at and again this is a
pointless discussion to have if you're
just gonna sit there and say industry
funding my point that islet that's not
my only point I think you're saying it
makes them suspect correct yes grieve
you about the cigarette thing how many
of the hundred and fifty three studies
meta-analysis which each also had
individual studies in them are are so so
biased by industry funding that we can't
count on the phone well I would hope
that you would know more than I I mean
basically you've lied why would you know
this is a this this we can't get very
far in this discussion if you're gonna
claim that we can't even talk about
studies in the peer-reviewed literature
because industry funding completely bias
is the finding no I'm not saying that's
the case I'm saying just because they
couldn't even though there were more
showing an increase East than showed a
decrease risk right I am saying that
it's possible that the the industry fund
that's a misleading statement more
showed increase than decreases Corral
but there's 71 percent showed no not me
with that all I agree I agree so that's
a wash but so no it's not even those two
hot no it's not a wash if you have a
hypothesis this thing causes cancer and
then you do a ton of studies and there's
no association that's on that hypothesis
is no longer
correct it's not a while that's actually
that's actually not true based on
epidemiology if you have ten studies
that show no association and ten that
show an association then you don't have
that at all I'm not what he said you
have 84% that shows the opposite you
could say 84% showed no evidence and
then you can forget about decreased risk
just say 84% showed no evidence forget
about decreased risk right you sit still
have only 16% showed an increase risk
right I'm gonna do an epidemiology study
or you have to take into account all the
other factors in these persons lives
totally about whether they whether they
drank whether they smoked total whether
they exercised suddenly well you know
sedentary lifestyle there's a lot of
factors so that would if you had
something that was causing cancer you
would expect the results to be flipped
you would expect the results to be 16%
showed no so it showed no evidence 71%
or 84% showed an increase that would be
something you'd say hey this is causing
cancer this is more like that's not
however demonology work so if you if you
had well epidemiology is slippery and I
agree is that not how epidemiology works
if you've got if you have even if you
had 10 studies showing no evidence just
cuz you don't find something doesn't
mean that it exists okay the absence of
evidence is not the evidence of absence
okay but let's say let's say this if you
if you had a hundred studies and 70 of
those studies showed an increased risk
of cancer would you say that thing
causes cancer most likely most Wow if it
is all epidemiology then it's okay so
now let's do 100 studies and 70% now
show no evidence yeah would you say it's
most likely that there's no evidence not
that's not how it works
oh so if you've got 70 studies that can
couldn't show a correlation and 30% that
did that is still in favor of showing
that there is a correlation what no no
no we're not now we're doing 70 study if
70% look it was 70 percent of the people
in these studies if you have all these
studies you have 100 studies and 70% of
the people in all these studies are
showing an increased risk of cancer we
would agree right this is why you can't
prove causation based on observational
but right now if it's reversed
now if 70% of these studies show there's
no increase
risk of cancer or 84% for 84 percent
which is because you add in the
decreased risk when we're not even
adding the decreased risk which shows
that you're less likely to get cancer
which is almost the same as an increased
risk of cancer which in my eyes is a
wash you would assume that we're talking
about something that doesn't give you
cancer well that I mean that that's I
agree that this study found that there
were they couldn't prove a causation
right it couldn't prove a link between
cancer but you made it out like he was
being deceptive is being deceptive I
don't agree that I don't know you're
trying to show that these studies are
proving or at least making this
correlation between consumption of dairy
products and cancer but the evidence
doesn't show that if you want to look at
it in its entirety the evidence shows
that most of the 71% showed no evidence
of it causing cancer
13% showed it's actually better for you
you have less risk of cancer than not
eating dairy 13% showed increased risk
of cancer and again when you talk about
epidemiology studies when you're talking
about you know 16 out of a hundred you
you have to throw in all the other facts
right and that's why they didn't find it
but can I just the reason you point this
up is prostate cancer right and and so
if you look at slide 113 prostate cancer
was that's disturbing so it's 5050 with
dairy consumption versus that's not 100
113 but a lot of people get prostate
cancer too isn't that an also an issue
that's a high as one person isn't that a
high risk for males prostate cancer yes
it's a high one whether it 112 whether
they consume milk or not so just I in
this mattress that you point to the
highest connection that they could find
between dairy and any type of cancer was
prostate cancer so if you look at the
black line that shows no association if
you look at the green line that's
decreased Association and the red line
was increased association that was the
meta-analysis that you provided yeah so
you brought you brought this study up
because dr. Walter Willett who is the
chair of nutrition Harvard he's one of
the most published nutrition scientists
of all time if not the most published a
disagreement right and so he is coming
to the determination that prostate
cancer
is length and it's likely that it's
causal and there's very slow up back up
1/2 and 1/2 that's not evidence of a
causal relationship dance there's no
evidence not a causal relationship ok
dr. Walter Willett is in just about any
type of study then yeah then appeal to
Authority you just said yourself that's
a rhetorical fallacy no it's it's a it's
a fallacy unless it's the appeal to
valid Authority because literally if I
want to know are you saying right so if
I want let's say we look at mixed
martial arts and Chris goes well I've
never done mixed martial arts but I
think I know more about anthropology
nutrition like I know more about boxing
kickboxing jiu-jitsu and wrestling so
we're telling people out the consensus
we're talking about leading experts in
their field with thousands out there
reviewed census there are experts who
would disagree and would look at this
study and reach the same exact
conclusion right I did there's no
reliable no there's no reliable proven
connection between dairy and prostate
you have half studies showing an
association half studies showing no
association not to mention the fact that
that's as you just said that even if
there was a strong correlation that
doesn't prove causation you said you
like this because it included also
randomized controlled trials yeah and I
think should a true be trust Walter
Willett who at the time was the chairman
trusted studies were way off here the
question was still you know the there
are a lot of inferences made in the film
whether they were intentional or not on
your part that you know dairy people are
hearing oh dear he's gonna cause
prostate cancer they're gonna extend
that to cancer there are other claims in
the film made about dairy and metabolic
prop and saturated fat and metabolic
issues so the operative question that
I'm trying to answer is do the data
support that not desalter will it think
that or any other expert in the film do
the data support that conclusion right
and even in that study it the data don't
strongly support that
if you have half studies saying yes half
studies saying no that's not a clear
signal and it's definitely not evidence
of a causal relationship so so having
Walter Willett or anyone say there's a
strong relationship and we know the
mechanism and there's you know its
causal that this person by the study can
I posit didn't you tell me that two
thirds of people have an intolerance
towards towards milk and dairy and I
have a study here is that what the
number is it's why not two out of three
people in the world okay so because this
is actually to your point so two out of
three people have an intolerance towards
dairy in the world and if you're talking
about a study that shows fifty percent
of the people in these studies that are
consuming dairy there's a correlation
between prostate cancer and and Derek
mm-hmm
wouldn't you assume that maybe what the
same thing that we're talking about with
two thirds of people are intolerant to
something they consume this thing that's
in tolerated inflammation in the body
and that inflammation the body could
possibly be leading to cancer correct
no not correct very primary is inversely
associated with inflammation so inverse
associated with inflammation but if
people are irritated by Dairy if they
have an intolerance to Dairy and you
said two-thirds of people here's here's
what I would suspect there that if you
we segmented those people out and said
let's do a study find out who's
intolerant of very and find out who
isn't you would see even better results
for dairy because despite the fact that
some people are lactose intolerant we're
still seeing in that meta-analyses that
you know most people there's no
association in most cases and a inverse
association in other cases hold on a
second but this prostate cancer thing is
not moles why this is 5050 right no and
but you're saying you're saying if half
okay but if dairy gives half people
cancer right and doesn't give their dog
answer then I can just think dairy
second of all do you see what Christmas
did that's not what that's Ted but you
see what in the ology James it's not
dairy gives anyone cancer its
association or that's
has included running my time this is
actually to you can I stop this though
wouldn't if someone's intolerant of
something that means your body is
irritated by it means it causes some
sort of disturbance right whether it's
inflammation or gastrointestinal
disorder you start farting and that's
what happens when people are lactose
intolerant right that irritates the body
wouldn't there be wouldn't you assume
that something your body is intolerant
to would possibly be the cause of
disruption or disease certain thing
could be right so now if every but if
you're looking at two-thirds of the
population are intolerant while you're
that cause prostate cancer and no other
cancers I don't make that's why it when
you see that kind of thing in the data
it's a red flag because there's no
logical explanation for why it would
cause prostate cancer but no other
cancer is there more of an association
there with with that Jamie pull up but
just Google dairy products and
inflammation review of the clinical
evidence and this is a review systematic
review of 52 clinical trials and they
found that dairy products were inversely
associated with inflammatory markers
which means that people who consume
dairy actually had lower levels of
inflammatory markers so the hypothesis
that dairy is inflammatory and that's
why it's causing cancer doesn't seem to
hold up in the literature so so can I
just say so first of all you know
there's this that might be studies he
can bring out I'm not even a nutrition
scientist I'm looking like a combatives
trainer right and so you also said that
you're not an expert in nutrition and so
what we have to believe today is that
Chris really is it is about the
meta-analysis but it's about
meta-analysis it's about the totality of
opinion can all the evidence not just
one meta-analysis or and meta-analysis
were meta analyses but all of the data
and so what you're asking people to
believe is that you are better at
interpreting the data than people that
are experts in their field
there are many experts who would agree
with me just didn't choose to interview
them in the film no actually we did
interview some that I can tell you about
in a second on the other side not to be
why we didn't include them but you are
asking people I would understand it if
suddenly chris has figured out this new
through our diet that he figures out
something about nutrition that he's
better than the consent he knows more
about the consensus and more about the
majority of leading experts but to
believe that Chris knows more about
anthropology urology heart disease new
environment apology because that what
you try to be anthropology and
successfully because a majority of
anthropologists agree with what I said
you chose the probably one of the few
that would agree with the idea that
humans primarily ate a plant you know
exclusively plant-based diet for
promotion of human evolution we can go
into that again I'm actually
representing the consensus view point in
anthropology James and you'd be
hard-pressed to find a consensus group
of experts that agree with that idea
[Applause]